next time
mark 6 front and center
so this implies a theoretical animal not
currently found on the periodic table I
think I will run a simulation to check
element viability yeah listen you have a
ball with that I know it's gonna work
missing shower tap the Oracle grid and
some stuff out of storage come
everything from projects Pegasus Exodus
and Goliath get ready for a major
remodel back in hardware mode how did
you broke the perimeter yeah that was
like three years ago where you been I
was doing some stuff yeah well me too
and it worked Land of Enchantment so I'm
told secret stuff something like that
how bad is it that's the problem sir we
don't know everybody it's Charlie so
there's a whole bunch of Captain Marvel
stuff going down we found out about a
new Easter Egg connecting it to the Iron
Man movies as well as the original
Avengers movie and a couple of other
things during phase one as well as the
fact that they just finished shooting
and there were a couple more Easter eggs
that were spotted like her cat for
instance I'll talk about that stuff in a
second too the big stuff as you probably
spotted from those clips is project
Pegasus so I'll explain what's going on
with that but if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's new giveaway
stuff all that splitting at the end of
the video - starting with the big stuff
project Pegasus is sort of the special
research group created by the world
security council that we saw during the
first Avengers movie this sort of
governed shield in the shield agents so
it's sort of like a subgroup of shield
meant to study phenomena beyond our
normal reach of understanding so back in
the early 90s Howard Stark was a
founding member of project Pegasus they
set up a special base in the Mojave
Desert that was the base that you saw
that they destroyed at the beginning of
the first Avengers film where they kept
the tesseract so it wasn't just a simple
place for studying the tesseract they
didn't create a base just for that it
had been something that existed since
after this ant-man flashback remember
that was an 89 so a couple years after
that Howard Stark shield in the world
Security Council create this special
mission called project Pegasus they
build a base out in the desert and they
use it as a place to test all their
really fantastic stuff like you also see
here on this list here you see this
joint NASA task force mission that's
also being run with shield that's also
Captain Marvel stuff will still go back
around to that in a second but then you
also see shield particle accelerator so
project Pegasus was sort of like this
base in this mission where they would
test all these special other projects
Captain Marvel was part of that because
she was part of the Air Force she was a
military person and so she don't come up
through this and all this shield stuff
that lasts Fury clip was also kind of
funny too because fury and Coulson will
appear during the Captain Marvel movie
Kevin Feige revealed that it would be
set entirely during the past they would
spend the entire movie with special D
aging technology so if you went to see
ant-man this weekend there was a brief
flashback
they show Michael Douglas and Michelle
Pfeiffer when they're young it looked
amazing imagine them doing an entire
movie with Colson and Nick Fury being D
aged like that so back to her
confirmation then most of Captain Marvel
takes place during the early to mid 90s
so you have to imagine that ninety one
project Pegasus is created just to study
any weird stuff that they happen upon on
planet earth Marvel crash lands on
planet earth we know there's a plane
crash because we've seen wreckage of it
and all the behind the scenes footage
they crashed on planet earth so that's
Jude Law's character Marvel from the
comics it becomes part of project
Pegasus now we don't know exactly how
they're going to be using them during
the movie but one of the people on the
IMDB is listed as a Pegasus guard
meaning that there will be scenes at
project Pegasus the Skrulls are also a
really big part of the Captain Marvel
movie we'll be meeting them in the MCU
for the first time I'm guessing that one
of the people working at project Pegasus
will turn out to be a scroll they'll
find them to be part of some sabotage
plot as they're trying to get all this
information from Marvel now they haven't
really explained what the new origin of
Captain Marvel is going to be in the MCU
I'll do a separate video about that
because there are a lot of new theories
based on the ways they've fundamentally
changed a brand new character that they
just introduced I'm trying not to do
spoilers because this isn't necessarily
an ant-man video but you also may have
noticed that during that clip of Tony
Stark he mentions project Goliath that
was the project that was referenced
during ant-man the wasp because Goliath
was part of Project Goliath like he was
the character from the comics so it's
just another easter egg tying this all
together so it shows you how far back
they were laying seeds for this way back
in Iron Man 2 and some stuff out of
storage from everything from projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath I was
partners with Hank on a project called
Goliath how big did you get by record 21
feet you 65 feet 65 just a little while
ago I posted a video talking about a
couple of those types of moments that
they reference in ant-man of the wasp so
if you haven't seen that movie be sure
to go see it because there are a couple
things that they're laying track for way
down the road now Howard Stark was
killed by the Winter Soldier along with
his wife in 1991 so I'm guessing that
they don't appear during the Captain
Marvel movie maybe within project
Pegasus there's a picture of him on
all somewhere but as probably as close
as we'll get to referencing him anything
they do in the 80s in before then in the
timeline this total fair game for Howard
Stark though the other brand-new Captain
Marvel Easter eggs we just learned about
come courtesy of samuel l.jackson it's
almost like he's vying for position on
spoiler bros he sees Tom Holland and
Mark Ruffalo just says hold my beer I
can do you one better
so we learned about Captain Marvel's
helmet from the comics appearing during
the movie I wouldn't call that ground
shattering I think it's just cool that
they're gonna try and do that we might
see a version of the mohawk if she puts
the helmet on we'll see what it actually
looks like that might wind up being a
Luke Cage Season one type moment where
he puts on the classic costume and says
you look like a damn fool and then takes
it right off the other one that he
dropped it was later confirmed in a post
that brie Larson made was chewy the cat
from the comics after Samuel Jackson
posted this brie Larson posted this to
celebrate the end of filming Captain
Marvel principal photography is
officially done they'll be reshoots
later this year but we'll get our
trailer in a couple months but at the
bottom of the picture you can see
there's Captain Marvel a little rocket
here and in a spaceship behind her is
the cat so it's like oh yeah they're
definitely many references to captain
Marvel's cat showing up all over the
place he's probably featured somewhere
in the movie just think ripley with her
cat
Jonesy from the Alien movies Jonesy made
it all the way to the second movie
that's one tough cat so we'll see what
they do with her cat during the Captain
Marvel movie without getting into
spoilers there are a lot of theories
about young Captain Marvel in modern day
if she's gonna be like 20 plus years
older than all the other characters
how can she still be young like brie
Larson based on the way they end Ant Man
of the wasp so just keep that in the
back of your mind when you go see
ant-man in the wasp this weekend or when
you go back to see it again I'll do a
new video about that in a couple days
too I'm just giving people a chance to
see the movie before I do a lot of big
spoilery videos leave all your video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to droid you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
is a new round of that infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner when I post new Marvel click here
for that Avengers 4 Ant Man of the wasp
Easter Egg and click here for my post
credits scene video thank you so much
for watching everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]